Charlie it's so Charlie yes so Charlie
is so you need my mug my mug is amazing
my mug features Homer Simpson my mug
holds exactly the right amount of tea my
mug is ergonomically designed my mug is
a Simpsons mug the Simpsons weekdays at
six o'clock on channel 4 every time I
learned something new
it pushes some old stuff out of my brain
you need my mug you want my mug this mug
is a gift to you it's rude to refuse a
gift you should be thanking me
I've had this mug for five years I got
it for Christmas it is the perfect mug
Homer Simpson's eyes have gone blue with
wear and tear blue eyes so please take
my mug take it take it take it
take my mug